I am Conan O'Brien, or as I'm known
here at Comic-Con, The Hound in the Streets
and Little Finger in the Sheets.
(Cheering)
I really should figure out what these mean
before I say them.
[Andy] Right, right exactly.
It's a huge mistake.
Ladies, I promise you
a night of not being divinated.
Yeah.
We're very excited, we have the cast
of Game of Thrones here.
(Cheering)
Very excited about that. Yeah.
In fact, in honor of the show tonight,
our entire audience is made up of actors
who were killed on Game of Thrones.
(Cheering)
Nicely done. Yeah, yeah.
And that was just in last week's episode.
Been a very exciting weekend across the country,
did you know this Andy?
Yes.
Yeah, very exciting.
There were some major releases this weekend
Dunkirk, Girls Trip, yeah,
O.J. Simpson.
(Laughter)
Another guy on his way out is Sean Spicer.
Sean Spicer,
(Cheering)
yeah
Sean Spicer has resigned as the White House Press Secretary.
(Cheering)
Oh wait,
but don't worry, he already got a new job
defending the good work of Hydra.
That is his new job, you know Hydra.
He's gonna work for Hydra now.
What a swag, what a swag at this year's Comic-Con.
This year at Comic-Con, DC unveiled 41 new collectibles.
Yeah, yes the collectibles are in pristine,
untouched condition, just like the people collecting them.
(Laughter)
(Cheering)
I've had a really strange week here at Comic-Con.
At my hotel, true story, I got hit on by a brony.
(Laughter)
I did. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had to tell him nay means nay, you know?
(Laughter)
I was waiting all week,
Neigh means neigh.
I have been wanting to to that all week.